raising debt ceiling raised the debt
ceiling raised the debt ceiling raised
the debt ceiling raising debt ceiling
raised the debt ceiling raised the debt
ceiling Raisinets you learn 14 trillion
in debt but yo we ain't got no crowd
$100 bills and billion dollar bond
vending money we don't have that's the
name of the gap they call me
cumulonimbus because y'all make it right
all kinds of cars got all kinds of where
people math me how I get on my table
simulators or Security surplus oh guess
what it's gone got my hands on
everything like that my next round I got
no Medicare drug run son that's just
observing and every single penny that we
season have you ain't got no moral
objection got no kind of complainant got
no monitor the statutory budget
restraints we today stealin raise the
debt ceiling raised the debt ceiling
raised the debt ceiling raised the debt
ceiling raised the debt ceiling raised
the debt ceiling raised the debt ceiling
oliver in the bed that we live in their
style bending lots of money while we sip
it cristão making it right in your MP
soap reason i say make it rain I mean
qualitative Yuri 1qe - can we walk you
return dropping out oh using everyone
that I see written the cash inflating
the monies calling up China y'all we
straight out of twenties all up in the
club we'd be louder now while in the
market can we be crowded out on the
beach can't an insipid Corona I got a
monetary plan involves a lot of
they raise the debt ceiling raised the
debt ceiling raised the debt to moon
break the debt ceiling raised the debt
ceiling raised the debt ceiling raised
the debt ceiling or if you look at the
chart and you examine the trend we
borrow 40 cents of every single dollar
we spend and non-discretionary spending
increases every day do you have a
comment for committee I make it right
mr. speaker mr. speaker could you beam
me up a Congress where's the cutting
spending couldn't dream me up but we're
all gonna default if we follow the road
you're not gonna thought of this which
increased hours ago cuz I'm the king of
the links I'm a menace antenna some
stickers banners on my rims picking
winners and bidders and whoops you're
looking for some cash cuz fix it get in
heaven I got some big old pile of money
guess what - of already raises debt
ceiling raised the debt ceiling raise
the debt ceiling
raise the debt ceiling and raising debt
ceiling raised the debt ceiling raised
the debt ceiling raise the debt ceiling
I'm telling what wasn't available in my
rap career
[Music]
you